[Music]
yeah we some Latinos with
attitud we some Latinos with attitud
yeah yeah yeah yeah doing me seem to be
working how you going to knock it which
the worst for me like empty jeans you
out of pocket B My Destiny since Grandma
dropped me off at Ma now vvs's got their
eyeballs popping out they socket I don't
[__] with 12 why she think I buy a
bouquet acting like a virgin [__] you
ain't guad Lupe keep the Poo tank pie
and deserted toue met on Monday never
spoke again right after Tuesday I'm back
on my neoo rappers is Pinocchio telling
fa not in their portfolio broke boys get
to talk and I'm like here we go speak
different languages like they grew up in
Tokyo can't be opinionated and
comfortable getting by living check to
check you got no business getting high
priorities all [__] up and I wonder
why Always focus and be worried about
the other guy your screen time this week
is up three hours and your bank account
balance falling like the towers the
audacity when ain't putting half of the
hour always banging on the net that's
how we know you a coward yeah I'm all
gas like a piston call me stag house I'm
grown still getting in trouble I love
the dog house couple baddies backing
work wearing a black blouse this ain't
mine this my baby mama trap house for
real can't compete with her how you
going to hang with me easy dub like we
paying off the referee and I'll be
chilling in the cut like an N y'all be
grilling more than chefs who work at
Applebees you mad huh hate to see
another man go get a bag huh hey keep
going I said you mad huh
ha to see another man get a bag huh look
blanco tick Tick boom [__] I'm out of
here Blanco I'm the [__] I'll be pooting
like I'm Vladimir Z got me on a whole
different Stratosphere got to check say
my name and then I'll appear hello even
though I'm mellow keep a stick on me
like my name is
Donatello just got a call from monabell
it's a freak ho that want me pulling on
her Bellow ooh I'm the one like Mr
Anderson stop front man you know this is
a Bangert why he always bring me up what
is wrong with him your man's a baby shut
him up and go pamper him all this wi to
make a grown man cry I don't just want a
slice want the whole damn pie I'm just
Chosen and I don't know why she slid up
in the DM hoping I reply not be some
Latinos with
Attitude be some Latinos with Attitude
hello yeah we started something
something rapping [__] yeah man yo these
[__] keev what's up dog got to
talk I got to tell talk I got to talk
about my life as I see yeah I got to say
how I see it you know what I'm saying
based from my angle [__] nobody out
there that could spit like this man you
know you know somebody that could [__] a
lot of [__] on the internet man
homies asking me yo you good you off the
med or something I'm like nah bro it's
the opposite I'm on like 20 of them
[__] dog I'm losing my marel
dog I got to get some [__] off my chest
yo yeah yeah yeah I got a semi-automatic
weapon a smithing Wesson a shotgun
loaded and it's point of your direction
I feel disrespected you smoking on Dust
this fool really thinks it's 40 people
better than us smoking Pooky got a bunch
of fools as your groupies you're still a
virgin I got two [__] in my jacuzzi
she said the man don't make them come I
get them both to finish when I'm done I
leave them there and throw a toaster in
it the most electrifying man on the
planet I pop his an it with the girl
that only speaking Spanish then I black
out right next to a beautiful ass I love
[__] but never loved the woman attach I
like my girl heavy not Brazilian wax
while you're in my business I'm inside a
gluty Maxs we're different selfmade what
a wonderful filling I'm the type to
watch a movie and I root for the villain
I agree with Thanos let's get rid of
half of the living middle child as a
youth I try to murder my siblings I'm
crazy they tell me I need therapy but no
thanks my lady telling me to sober up
there's no chance she like it's Tuesday
why you got to drinking both hands it's
2:00 and you still ain't wearing no
pants huh I walk around the crib with my
dick out paranoid looking out the window
with the Blick out six feet fully tatted
wonder why I stick out walk inside a
party women greet me with they tit out
I'm schizophrenic I got three different
lives and they all monogamous man I got
three different wives every day I go to
work but I got three different jobs I'm
a rapper I'm a barber I so dick on the
side I let one of them take over when
I'm too drunk to drive if my vision
spinning I just cover one of my eyes had
the doctor check my health he said I'm
barely alive said my heart is barely
working that [__] double in size he told
me pick the water up and put the boo
down your people need you you the leader
of the fools now we the reason being
Mexican is cool now coyote we the dopest
[__] fools out yeah that's a
fact man when you talk about La you got
to mention the [__] yodis man
there's 40 people that could do that
better than us I don't think so yeah
[__] you go get some [__] dog shots
fired yeah hey appreciate you guys
watching this freestyle we got another
one coming and then another one and then
another one and they're all brought to
you by our good Folks at LRG clothing
you already know what it is LRG been
keeping you fly for years they got so
much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30% off
l-r-g.com another freestyles on the way
presented by LRG